let's go back to the phones I think
we're going to go with our caller from
the nine five six area code
caller from nine five six of what's your
name where are you calling from and feel
free to jump right in to what's on your
mind today uh yes hello my name is Pablo
you can hear me right we can hear you
fine yeah what's on your mind problem
yes I am from Mission Texas okay and I
just I just want to call real quickly
about a something has been on my mind
you know and I know 2020s far away far
away from now like a long time now but I
figured that this be the only time I'd
ever talk to you so yeah you know Bernie
Sanders I'm I've correct me if I'm wrong
Bernie Sanders she said he's not a
Democrat right am I correct well looked
and I mean yeah it Bernie Sanders has
been an independent senator he has
caucused with Democrats I think that at
this point it's more a discussion of
what you know it's an in name only thing
we sort of have an understanding of his
politics such that I don't know that it
matters if he's a Democrat or not but
what's your question based on that oh as
it was because uh science is another's
discuss I was worried that if he might
not run as a Democrat because like Kyle
Koontz key from secular talk like he
said that if he were to run as a in the
third party or you know others and but
as an independent is like running a
marathon and but like hitting yourself
and their leg with like a hammer son
like that and I feel like if you were to
run as an independent he that would be
true but I just feel I am confused and I
am a little scared that he would run as
at run as an independent because that
would happen but at the same time if you
were if you were if he were to run as a
Democrat in 2020 I feel like they would
just just do the same thing
like it didn't done 16 okay very good so
here's my thought on this Pablo
basically I have two thoughts number one
your first instinct was correct which is
it is way too early to be talking about
2020 and the Democratic primary or the
presidential race for 2020 right now the
White House Office of Science and
Technology now has no employees left
right I mean we've got some pretty
pretty insane stuff going on right now
in the 2018 election special elections
this year my broader thought though is
Bernie Sanders is going to be closing in
on 80 years old in the time that he
would be inaugurated in January of 2021
and I actually don't know that it's in
the advantage to the advantage of
progressives for Bernie Sanders to run
in the 2020 election I am NOT taking a
position on that right now but I think
that we should not just assume pat that
Bernie 2020 is the thing yeah but I
would take a 78 or 79 year old Bernie
Sanders over a 74 year old Donald Trump
any day assure absent you know he could
have competitors in a Democratic primary
race who levy the charge that well
you're not a real Democrat at Martin
O'Malley did that in 2016 but that
doesn't really stick I don't think
people really care about that issue it's
more about your politics and if you're
actually a progressive or not it was
more used you know where he's not a real
Democrat thing was used more Pablo it
was after the fact to counter accurate
allegations of the DNC
interfering in the primary and you had a
lot of Hillary supporters retro actively
saying Bernie wasn't really a Democrat
anyway so the DNC was right to interfere
but I generally agree with Pat on that
Pablo wait can I just say one thing real
quickly before I end the call yeah um
like like I get you saying that uh
Bernie Sanders 22news might not be the
best idea like mostly because some
there's a lot of people who would not
vote for Bernie Sanders because of this
age which i think is ridiculous because
the fact that you know for a Bernie
Sanders will be 79 in 2020 so of poor
man who's in his late 70s
he's pretty fine is not that you know
all wrinkly to not like looking my
like my grandpa and stuff like he keeps
the walk I'm ray like I'm just saying
he's still fit like you saying hey you
know his basketball shooting was pretty
pretty much on point good point point
taken Pablo appreciate the call thank
you thank you very much appreciated and
I think that there will be plenty of
time to talk about this in detail